investigators are also learning more
about the gunman's state of mind some of
that information comes from paddocks
girlfriend Marilu dan lee who returned
to the u.s. from the philippines after
the shooting jeff Piquet's is in
washington with the clues from dan lee's
FBI interviews Jeff good morning good
morning officials have told CBS News
that during the FBI's four hours of
questioning Dan Lee said that she was
concerned about paddocks mental
stability last night the police
recovered the couple's Hyundai Tucson at
their home in Reno they bought the car
just two months before the shooting at a
local dealership they paid for it up
front with a check for about fourteen
thousand four hundred dollars employees
tell CBS News that Dan Lee was extremely
complimentary of Patek and that he said
and that and she said that he saved her
from an abusive relationship with her
ex-husband just blocks away at the
Atlantis casino where Dan Lee worked as
a high-limit hostess and reportedly met
Patek and acquaintances described the
suspected shooter as a high-roller who
spent days at a time playing video poker
he says while paddock was a bit of a
loner he never saw any big red flags
paddock was a black diamond member at
the Atlantis casino which gave him
access to VIPs services including a host
who would have been on call for him
Charlie thanks Jeff